[Musique]
incuballiance et l'incubateur mutualisé
du plateau de saclay spécialisée dans
l'accompagnement des start-up deep tech
nous avons constaté depuis très
longtemps une problématique pour les
projets deep tech qui est le
rapprochement avec des associés souvent
le
chercheur l'ingénieur arrive avec son
idée mais n'a pas forcément d'associer
pour pouvoir l'aider à commercialiser
son produit sur le marché
ce constat il est véritablement premier
dans le monde de la start up et pour le
résoudre avec pôle emploi nous avons
décidé de mettre en place
un programme qui va permettre de
présenter aux start-up des demandeurs
d'emploi et les fameuses start up qui
elles sont en recherche d'assez sud
c'est absolument innovant c'est une
démarche qui n'avait jamais été
effectués auparavant
et cette démarche a déjà porté ses
fruits puisque nous avons quatre
rapprochement qui ont été faits alors
que nous avons
fait déjà uniquement deux séances de
rapprochement le principe est assez
simple nous mettons en place lorsque
deux personnes ont décidé de travailler
ensemble un programme de formation le
demandeur d'emploi entre en formation
chez incuballiance et incuballiance va
le délégué en stage sous forme d'un
stage auprès de la start up et ce
pendant une période maximale de six mois
durant ces six mois
le demandeur d'emploi et les associés en
clair seront coachés suivi sur la partie
rh la partie relations humaines et ainsi
que sur toute la partie développement de
l'entreprise
ce programme
a pour objectif de pouvoir aider les
demandeurs d'emploi à se socialiser pour
certains à réintégrer à profiter de
leurs noah aussi je puis dire et leur
carnet d adresses pour être mis au
service des start up qui elle en général
n'ont pas cette chance et non pas cette
expertise a mis cette expérience pour
nous c'est un dispositif qui démarre à
orphée incuballiance et qu'on pourrait
imaginer étendre au département et même
au delà au niveau de la région et
pourquoi pas un moment donné créer une
application un service numérique qui
permettrait de remettre en relation les
demandeurs d'emplois à grande échelle
avec des besoins des start up ça ça peut
être la poste une perspective réelle
dans l'est dans l'année dans les deux
ans qui viennent